Let's talk seriously about polling for a little
bit because the amount of misinformation around
polling, right?
Yeah.
Right now is just massive.
Every time I talk about this, I take heat,
but I don't care.
I'll tell you what I think.
If you don't like it, there are other shows
you can watch that will maybe tell you what
you want to hear about polls.
If you actually want to engage with me and
telling me what I'm not understanding, then
listen to or watch the entire segment and
then get in touch with me and then I will
issue any necessary corrections.
Backstory on polling Biden pre his announcement
was around 20% polling.
A lot of people wrote in and said, David,
it's bs.
Uh, Bernie for a while was leading, uh, among
the non declared candidates with 18 to 20%.
Biden was 20 to 24.
Okay.
Eventually, uh, Joe Biden declared his candidacy
shot up according to a number of polls to
more than 40%.
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren saw some declines.
Bernie bottomed out at about 14%.
However, last week I told you that Joe Biden
started to sort of trail off in the polls
a little bit.
We now seem to be having sort of a, uh, homeostasis
taking place in equilibrium, so to speak,
because Joe Biden has been leveling off and
Bernie Sanders has been leveling off.
Now I'll deal with the believability of these
poles shortly.
Don't think I'm going to skip that, but it
appears as though now in a number of recent
polls, Joe Biden down from 40 42% to 35 Bernie,
uh, roughly 17% in numerous consecutive polls,
really stabilizing and Elizabeth Warren continuing
to pick up about a point to a point and a
half per month up to about 10%.
So there are immediate questions.
Can we trust these numbers or are the poles
totally fake rigged nonsense question to do.
The polls really mean anything this early.
And number three, what would move the needle
in terms of polling for the candidates at
this point in time?
First question, can the polls be trusted?
Listen, more or less, they can be.
And here's why I believe that they can be.
There are people who write to me and they
say, David, the polls are straight up, made
up, out of thin air.
It's just plucked out of thin air.
The polling companies aren't really doing
polls.
The DNC is dictating what the polls should
say.
They are completely and totally made up.
If that's true, then eventually the election
results should be completely not in line with
the Poles.
And at a certain point, someone's going to
need to present some evidence if they believe
that the polls are literally concocted out
of thin air.
Remember the claim in 2016 was the polls are
fake and rigged.
Uh, and uh, we can't trust them on.
And Hillary, well, the national popular vote
polls showed Hillary up two or three points
and she won the popular vote by a couple of
points, which is exactly what the polls said.
Yeah, I get it.
She lost the electoral vote because of about
70,000 votes in three states.
But anyone saying the polls are way off.
I mean, listen, even in the states where she
was slightly ahead and lost, it was within
the margin of error.
The national polls were right, Hillary plus
two or three, and that's what it was.
So I don't believe the polls are completely
fake, is a valid assertion.
And until someone gives me some evidence that
that's the case, that's not my view.
Now is the methodology poor on some individual
polls?
There are arguments to be made there.
Yeah.
CNN poll from a couple of months ago that
uh, I believe didn't even include young people
in the final sampling.
That's crazy.
If I, if I'm recalling it correctly, the more
recent polls are more or less right?
In their methodology.
Harvard Harris Morning Consult Co Quinnipiac,
Monmouth, the hill, Harris x, Fox News, but
you really have to look closely.
For example, people have looked at the Harvard
Harris Poll and said, David, it's way over
weighted for older folks, only 15% of the
population is over 65 but the pole sampled
65 plus year olds at 21% 21% in the poll.
There are only 15% of the population.
It's fake and skewed and wrong.
Hold on a second though.
This is a likely voter model.
65 plus are the most likely group to vote
every election.
So it makes sense that 65 plus folks would
be overrepresented relative to their population
because more of them vote relative to their
population size.
So again, if you believe it's all fake and
made up, I probably can't change your mind.
If you want to look at the specific issues
with each pole.
Okay, here we're talking about 21% of the
sample is over 65 which makes sense because
even though they make up 15% of the population,
they're the highest percentage voting group.
So if you go through it all and you can find
areas to nitpick and each pole, but the results
are quite similar.
They've stabilized, so short of an out and
out total conspiracy where the DNC says to
the polling companies, here's what you publish.
We're going to get a pretty good idea from
these polls.
This gets us to question two.
Does it make sense to look at polls this early?
Do the polls tell us anything this early about?
Who's going to win?
Well, let's look at polls from June of 2015.
June of 2015 is equivalent to June, 2019 in
that it's June of the year before the election
year.
The 2016 Democratic primary polling at this
point in the 2016 election had, uh, ABC poll
had Clinton 62 Biden, 14 Sanders, 10 CNN,
Oh, RC had Clinton 60.
Fox News had Clinton 57 and Reuters had Clinton
49.
So at this point in the 2016 primary, the
polls were indicating Hillary would win and
Hillary did win the primary.
Now the DNC meddled we've condemned it.
I supported Bernie.
Remember we've talked about it all.
The point is if you look at the 2016 Democratic
primary or other examples, at this point in
time, uh, the polls do have meaning, which
gets us lastly to what would change the Poles.
And for me right now, it's debates.
Uh, I believe that Elizabeth Warren, Andrew
Yang and Pete booted judge, although I'm not
a, I'm not a huge [inaudible] fan, I think
they have the best chance of improving their
polling based on the debates.
I believe that Joe Biden, um, it is unlikely
to have a big surge in the debates.
He may trail off a little bit based on debate
performance.
I think Bernie Sanders is roughly going to
hold even after the debates.
Maybe pick up a couple of points.
I believe that it is Warren Yang and booted
judge who have the most to gain in the immediate
from the debates.
Let me know what you think.
I'm ready for it.
If you believe that the polls are straight
up fake, totally fake news, concocted out
of thin air, let me know and give me some
evidence if you believe that the polls at
this point in time me nothing.
Give me some historical evidence and if you
have a different view about who might be helped
by the debates, also let me know.